[Music]
next author and Washington Post
journalist Rick Atkinson talks about his
book in the company of soldiers a
chronicle of combat in Iraq at Ballard
high school in Louisville Kentucky
Ballard high school is located just
outside Fort Campbell Kentucky home of
the US Army's 101st airborne the same
division in which the author was
embedded during the war in Iraq the talk
is just under an hour he's a great
writer a good guy and a phenomenal
scholar that's Major General David
Petraeus his description of our guest
lecturer this evening Rick Atkinson mr.
Atkinson spent virtually all day every
day at the elbow of Major General
General Petraeus the 101st Airborne's
commander in Iraq born on a military
post in Germany our speaker is a
self-described
army brat after graduating from the
University of Chicago with a master's
degree Ric Atkinson's journalistic
career began in Kansas where he worked
for six years for the Kansas City Times
a former staff writer and assistant
managing editor at The Washington Post
he wrote most of the newspapers lead
stories on the Persian Gulf War based on
this experience he wrote crusade a
narrative history of the Persian Gulf
War he also covered the 50th anniversary
commemorations of the liberation of
Europe from Normandy to the fall of
Berlin and experience that reawakened
his passion for the history of the
Second World War which he describes as
quote the greatest story of the 20th
century his many awards include the 1982
Pulitzer Prize for national reporting
and the 1999 felissa prize for public
service his current project is the
three-volume history of the Allied
liberation of Europe in world war ii a
trilogy scheduled for completion in five
years the first volume and army at dawn
the war in North Africa 1942 to 1943 one
to 2003 pilet surprise
for the soldiers in the 101st Airborne
Division the road to Baghdad began with
a midnight flight out of Fort Campbell
in late February 2003 and honestly
recounted in mr. atkinson's book and the
company of soldiers his topic tonight
please join me in welcoming once again
Rick Atkinson to Louisville and to the
Gertrude Polk Brown lecture series
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for that generous introduction
mark and thanks to you all for coming
tonight this is my second visit to this
gracious City in the past nine months
and I'm grateful to the Filson
Historical Society for inviting me back
so quickly I've seen friends in the
audience tonight and it's always
gratifying furling really to be in a
room full of people who love books and
to share a passion for history and are
interested in our common heritage well
when I was here last June we talked
about World War two and specifically the
campaign in North Africa in 1942 in 1943
when the American army first confronted
the German and Italian armies and I'm at
work now on volume 2 of my so-called
liberation trilogy and it will focus on
the next step after North Africa the
campaigns in Sicily and Italy in 1943
and 1944 but I'm not going to talk about
that tonight perhaps next time or
perhaps it'll come up in our
question-and-answer period because I'm
going to talk for a while tonight and
then we're going to talk back and forth
to each other I'm looking forward to
hearing what you have to say in your
questions and tonight I'm going to talk
first about something that's more
contemporary to all of us and certainly
close to the citizens of Kentucky since
the hundred and first Airborne is a
gathering of native sons and daughters
of Kentucky let me begin by asking first
how many people in the audience are
either in the military now active or
reserve component or have served in the
military in the past would you raise
your hands Wow
thank you for your service
[Applause]
[Music]
well the historian will Durant once
calculated that in all of human history
there have only been 29 years when there
was not a war in progress somewhere
sadly not one of those 29 years has
unfolded during the lifetime of anyone
in this room or is our lot it's where we
live it shapes our culture our history
and our souls individually and
collectively it shapes us to the extent
that a man named J Glen Gray who was a
veteran of the Italian campaign in World
War two suggests that Homo sapiens
should perhaps be renamed home offe
urines man the fighter war is also my
theme for four books now because it is a
lens for looking at us for understanding
some part of who we are even if at times
it requires looking through a glass
darkly in the company of soldiers is
ostensibly a book about my time with a
hundred and first Airborne Division from
the time we left Fort Campbell in
February 2003 until the time I left them
in Baghdad in mid-april
2003 the division 17,000 strong with
almost 260 helicopters staged in Kuwait
particularly at a seared pestilential
bivouac called Camp New Jersey
then attacked up the western edge of the
Euphrates River Valley with sharp
firefights in the cities of najaf and
karbala and Hill ah conditions were
austere for ten days we bivouacked in a
remote patch of nowhere called Forward
Operating Base shell the army and its
wisdom had named these bases after oil
companies
in a war that had absolutely nothing to
do about oil there is Exxon shell and
eventually Conoco was supposed to go in
near Baghdad here's a brief description
of what it was like by mid-afternoon on
Tuesday March 25th just a year ago the
weather was not only worse than it had
been on Monday it was worse than it had
ever been in the long sorry history of
Mesopotamia or so we prefer to believe a
fierce storm that like this one blows
out of the south is known as a to rob
but everyone in the hundred and first
Airborne Division insisted on calling it
a Shamal which is a wind from the north
perhaps because Shamal had a plague of
frogs ring to it the goggled soldiers
pulling guard duty sat in burrows with
neck gaiters pulled up around their ears
at 5:00 p.m. there was a commotion
outside I pushed through the flap of the
plans tent in time to see a towering
black storm wall bearing down from the
South kicking a brown cloud of debris
before it I retreated inside and moments
later the tent shuddered as if given a
great SWAT the wind shrieked in a gritty
miasma filled the tent then sheets of
rain lashed the camp
each drop congealing with the suspended
dust a soldier spattered from helmet to
Boot Hill pushed into the tent and
exclaimed it's raining mud a few minutes
later I looked outside again not only
had the sky turned red from the Setting
Sun refracting through the dust but the
very air was crimson as though the
atmosphere itself was hemorrhaging it
all seemed ominous and biblical well
I'll only add that there were two
examples of soldier graffiti that seemed
especially apt for these conditions
one read the only difference between
this place and the moon is a little
gravity and the other read if you'd
voted for Gore you wouldn't be here this
book is drawn overwhelmingly from what I
saw heard smelled tasted and felt with
all the advantages and disadvantages a
first-person picaresque narratives
although I also had access to thousands
of pages of documents that helped
clarify what I was seeing hearing
smelling tasting and feeling
after-action reports situation reports
intelligence analyses battlefield oral
histories and so forth my ambition on
the most basic level was to write in the
tradition of a genre that I've come to
appreciate and deeply admire while
researching world war ii the battle
memoir and among examples are the battle
is the payoff by Ralph Ingersoll who had
been managing editor of The New Yorker
in Fortune magazine's before going to
North Africa in 1943 brave men by ernie
pyle the road back to paris by aj
Liebling Purpleheart valley by margaret
bourke-white
who was a photographer and also a very
fine writer a more recent example from
the Persian Gulf War in 1991 would be
martyrs day by the fine writer Michael
Kelly who died April 3rd of last year
just outside of Baghdad when the Humvee
was in flipped over and he drowned in a
canal along with the soldier
specifically I'm writing about what the
British used to call the PDI the poor
bloody infantry Ernie Pyle memorably
called them the
mud rain frost and wind boys it's a
wonderfully apt moniker except you
forgot dust troops in the hundred and
first Airborne for weeks lived in a
thick layer of brown talc that became
for all of us
a fifth element along with fire earth
air and water
the soldiers coined a phrase in the
ironic idiom that is the signature of
modern soldiers at war which quickly
became a battle cry for all of us
embrace the suck Samuel Heins who is a
professor of literature at Princeton has
observed that combat narratives as he
put it make war vivid they don't make it
familiar indeed one motive for writing
them seems to be to show how unfamiliar
war is a strange and desolate it's
ordinary scenes are Hines also writes in
a terrific book called the soldier's
tale historians tell the big stories of
campaigns and battles of the great
victories and disastrous defeats
assigning credit and blame turning Wars
chaos into order the men who were there
tell a different story one that is often
quite a historical even anti historical
a part of my ambition is to try to
reconcile the two to square the circle
to tell a story that is fundamentally
experiential a historical that captures
what it smells like without forfeiting
the historians effort to confess
from disorder and I think Hines is
entirely right that a writer writing
about war should make it vivid without
making it familiar should embrace the
strange and desolate here's an example
of what I mean
it's drawn from the attack by the
hundred and first Airborne on the city
of Najaf it's the end of March of last
year and we're very close to the sacred
tomb the golden dome of Olli who was the
Prophet Muhammad's son-in-law it's
Monday March 31st and I was standing
with General David Patraeus commander
the hundred and first and Colonel Ben
Hodges who was the commander of the 1st
brigade of the hundred and first who by
the way had been wounded at the very
beginning of the war by grenade
splinters when one of his sergeants
threw several grenades into three
sleeping tents wounding two officers and
wounding 14 you'll remember that episode
it was awful and here's the scene
several prisoners under guard shuffled
down the road their hands cuffed and
their faces so coated with flies as to
appear masked overhead I heard the
muffled growl of US Navy f-18s a gbu-12
bomb detonated with a splash of flame
followed by a rolling boom another
exploded in another until five bombs had
smashed the bunker line billowing smoke
hid the golden dome a platoon of abrams
tanks clanked down the road and soon the
boom of their 120 millimeter main guns
echoed against the trees through Colonel
Hodges borrowed glasses
I could see shells gouged a facade of a
four-story white building which the
Fedayeen the Iraqi regulars had
converted into a fortress the hysterical
cackle of 50 caliber machine guns
mingled with the thud of mark-19 grenade
launchers several Humvees scooted across
a field into firing positions and a
barrage of tow missiles erupted with a
white whoosh before smashing into the
building
kaya's Kiowa helicopters darted along
the trees and up over the escarpment
hammering the Iraqi positions with
machine guns and hundreds of rockets
eight hundred men from the second
battalion of the three hundred and
twenty seventh infantry patted down the
road in their infantry Waddell and soon
vanished into the treeline it was all so
fierce
so terribly fierce a symphony of fire it
was combined arms at its most lethal the
relentless orchestration of air armor
artillery infantry and all the other
killing modalities it was combined and
in the Pentagon's vernacular it was
joint
with the army complemented by Navy Air
Force and Marine aircraft the US
military for sixty years had worked to
make this the signature of American
firepower and no other nation could
approximate such a synchronized
application of violence until recently
this had been the province of senior
generals but now I could see that it was
routine for Colonels and captain's and
sergeants on the battlefield to summon
the Jeanne's of the air and the earth
and the sea and to SiC them on the enemy
well having said that and while
reaffirming my great admiration for the
competence and the fortitude of our
soldiers at all ranks I think it's
important to remember that war by its
very nature is imperfect things go wrong
sometimes things go as wrong as they can
go and there's a scene in the company of
soldiers that occurs a few days after
this attack I've just described in Najaf
where we're in Karbala and the
coordination between ground forces and
air forces is rather ragged it's so
ragged that at one point an Air Force
maverick missile detonated behind where
General Petraeus and
I were standing with his command group
on the south edge of karbala and I will
not now be labor the deficiencies and
planning for the post-war occupation of
Iraq we can discuss that during the
question and answer period if you like
but obviously there were significant
shortcomings that play out to this day
and finally I think we have to
acknowledge that the Iraqi armed forces
were fundamentally inept the army the
Iraqi army in particular had
deteriorated considerably even from the
rather ineffective army we fought in the
Persian Gulf War in 1991 and I'll give
you one example of the imbalance and
even the weirdness of the Iraqi army in
March 2003 a year ago it was about the
same size as the u.s. army roughly half
a million soldiers the US Army has just
over 300 generals and 3,500 Colonels the
Iraqi army same size at 11,000 generals
and thirteen thousand kernels if nothing
else it's fair to say it was excessively
led
on a second and perhaps deeper level
this book is about character
I've long presumed that war is a great
revealer of character the extravagant
stress of combat refracts character
allowing you to see its basic components
in the same way a prism refracts light
allowing you to see the inner spectrum
and I had the good fortune to be in the
company of some fine soldiers his
character was in fact revealed and they
range from Lieutenant General Scott
Wallace the corps commander a great
native son of Kentucky and he was the
senior army commander in Iraq two men
like Warrant Officer Mark Daniels who
was a senior blackhawk helicopter pilot
and on several occasions through sheer
competence and courage saved our lives
but the book is really built around one
soldier and as Mark said I was at his
elbow in Iraq virtually all day every
day
his name is Major General David Howe
Petraeus and he's the commander of the
hundred and first Airborne Division and
let me tell you a little bit about him
his aide describes him as the most
competitive man on the planet
Dave Petraeus is the son of a Dutch sea
captain who took refuge in New York when
World War two began after graduating
near the top of the West Point class of
1974 Petraeus married the Academy
superintendents daughter Holly Knowlton
and he worked as an aide for several of
the Army's most prominent four-star
generals and in between command and
staff assignments he earned a doctorate
in international relations from
Princeton he's the only man I know to
survive both the collapse of his
parachute in a skydiving accident so
that he plummeted to the earth and
shattered his pelvis and an m-16 bullet
in the chest during a training accident
when he was a battalion commander hit
him right here
soldier tripped rifle discharged 40 feet
away and blew right through his chest
and out his back
Petraeus first uttered a tongue-in-cheek
query about a week into the war last
year which became a private joke between
us and which remains relevant today
a year later tell me how this ends well
here's a quick view of Dave Petraeus
it's early March of 2003 it's a couple
weeks before the war began and we've
driven to the docks in Kuwait City where
one of the cargo vessels bringing the
helicopters and other equipment for the
hundred and first has just birth ships
called the Bob Hope and Petraeus is
particularly eager for the stevedores to
find the enormous white headquarters
tent that will be used for his command
post in combat it'll be the Tactical
Operations Center the TOC and wags and
the division called this big white thing
the TOC Mahal
so here we see the commanding general
boarding the ship Petraeus stocked up
the ramp climbed the ladder to the
weather deck and swept back down the
ramp okay whoo Air Assault he called
slapping backs and flashing thumbs up
hooah Air Assault keep working this
thing good work guys on the pier near
the stern
he stopped long enough to banter with a
private first class named Jonathan al
Shire one thing led to another and
within 30 seconds the 50 year old
commanding general had challenged the 19
year old PFC to a push-up contest they
dropped to the concrete as a small
circle of soldiers gathered round like
schoolboys ringing a playground fight
all right here's the standard Petraeus
said chest touches the ground arms out
and locked he smiled
just stay with me stiff as an ironing
board eyes fixed on L Shire a trace dip
throws dip rose so did a liar five six
seven the watching soldiers counted and
shouted encouragement 11 12 13 neck
veins bulged 18 19 20 at 27 PFC ale
Shire gasped and collapsed on the
concrete Petraeus did 20 more and popped
to his feet without breaking a sweat
rocking up on his toes thumbs hooked
into his flak vest he told the panting
young soldier you can write that off on
your income tax as part of your
education
as we climb back into the car a sergeant
who had combed the Bob Hope for the
missing division main tent came up to
the passenger window sir it's not on the
ship I've been through the entire hold
son of a [ __ ] betrayus said softly heck
of a note rain began to spit as we left
the port Petraeus said there are times
when I think damn I hope they know what
they're putting us through and the
immutable truth is that they never do
a very interesting man an extremely
competent commander we're lucky to have
him in the senior ranks of our army let
me briefly address the political
component of in the army at dawn I'm
sorry in the company of soldiers it's
not a political book it's not a screed
or a polemic Lord knows we have enough
of those on the bestseller lists these
days but I don't think anyone who
finishes the book will have much doubt
about my views on the legitimacy or the
propriety of the Iraq war of 2003 I was
skeptical about the cassis belly the
cause of war before the war began and
I'm skeptical about it and now I've been
skeptical since I left Baghdad to me the
saddest number in America today is 577
that's how many American soldiers have
died in Iraq in the past year and also
as a scholar of World War two my reading
of history suggests that if you're going
to fight a global war whether it's
against the Axis powers in the 1940s or
international terrorism in the 21st
century
nothing is more vital than nurturing a
powerful righteous coalition and I'm
dismayed frankly at our thumb and the I
approach to our closest friends which
only increases the burden on our
military
and yet having said that I think it's
essential that we not confuse the
Warriors with the war
this is a book centered on the Warriors
not their war toward the end of the last
chapter I offer this assessment soldiers
in the hundred and first had done well
demonstrating competence and
professionalism capably led they took
hardship in stride and refused to let
bloodlust cynicism or other despoilers
of good armies cheat them of their
battle honors and I add this personal
judgment which readers are welcome to
take or leave it's neither right nor
wrong it's a judgement the soldiers were
better than the cause they served I do
believe we all should be concerned about
whether the US Army is excessively
stretched and stressed before September
11 2001 roughly 20% of the active duty
the United States Army was deployed
overseas two years later the figure had
climbed to nearly half 10,000 soldiers
in Afghanistan five thousand in the
Balkans thirty-seven thousand in South
Korea 120 thousand in Iraq and troops
scattered in more than 110 other
countries last June at his retirement
ceremony the Army's outgoing chief of
staff general Eric Shinseki warned
beware the 12 division strategy for a10
division army and no less strained as
many of you here know or the National
Guard and the reserves there are many
tens of thousands of Guardsmen and
reservists now on active duty worldwide
and a sign that you sometimes see in
reserve bivouacs and I saw it in Iraq a
couple times observes one weekend a
month my ass
we have a responsibility to own the army
jointly it's not President Bush's army
any more than it was President Clinton's
army it is our army and one of the acts
of citizenship should be to take a
vested interest in the faith of our army
we hang with it or we hang together
without it and as a final political note
I would only recall Machiavelli's words
wars begin where you will but they do
not end where you please well on the
deepest level my ambition in writing
about war is to transcend the
particulars of time place and even
character to approach something that's
timeless and placeless to convey an
emotional truth and that I suppose is a
truth that isn't right or wrong in a
rigidly empirical or historiographical
sense but one that is evaluated on the
basis of how it resonates writers of
military history have an inherent
advantage in their subject matter
because war carries a natural emotional
charge like a proton carrying an
electrical charge it's about life and
death I also am convinced having now
watched it for a long time in places
like Somalia and Bosnia and Iraq twice
that war is corrupting even good Wars or
righteous Wars eventually it does bad
things to good soldiers and I don't mean
it makes them capable of committing
atrocities and I certainly don't mean to
suggest in any way that service and
sacrifice are diminished but it's
corrosive of decency and nobility it
tarnishes the spirit the best example I
can think of is Wilfred Owen the great
English poet who commanded a platoon in
World War one and who not long before
his death just before the end of the war
describe sorting through the incoming
mail of his soldiers who had just been
killed and Owen wrote my senses are
charred I don't take the cigarette out
of my mouth when I write deceased over
their letters part of the writer's task
is to watch for this corruption to
document it because it reminds us that
as a general proposition peace is better
than war and if you think that seems
obvious all you have to do is remember
robert e lee's bromide that it is good
that war is so terrible or men should
grow to love it too much or more
recently the observation by the writer
in Vietnam veteran Phil Caputo who
described the compelling attractiveness
of combat and I suspect many of you in
this room know exactly what I'm talking
about I am much taken with the scholar
Paul Fussell's concept of history
illuminated by emotion in his phrase
Russell writes about the British
historian Martin Gilbert it is as if to
gilbert objective historiography is not
merely impossible but inhuman
offensively heartless and insensitive to
him the writing of history is not a
science but distinctly one of the
humanities and only those with deep
feelings for the human predicament
should try it I'd like to close before
we open it to questions by introducing
you to a single soldier who is
emblematic of soldiers in an age when
wars are small sequential expeditionary
and bottomless this is from the prologue
of in the company of soldiers they found
the sergeant's body at mid-morning on
Saturday April 12th 2003 just where an
Iraqi boy said it would be
in a shallow grave in South Baghdad near
the highway 8 cloverleaf known to the US
Army as objective Curley his interment
was imperfect an elbow and a knee
protruded from the covering rubble he
had been stripped of boots and combat
gear but not his uniform and his rank
stripes and the name tape sewn over his
right breast pocket made identification
easy sergeant first class John W
Marshall who had been missing since
Iraqi forces ambushed his convoy below
Curley on April 8th a rocket-propelled
grenade had ruined sergeant Marshalls
back and arm for days in the ground had
spoiled the rest of him soldiers from
the hundred and first Airborne Division
recorded the map grid of his makeshift
burial plot MB four four nine six two
seven five two nine five and a chaplain
read from Psalms by the time I arrived
at the site the remains had been lifted
into a body bag draped with an American
American flag and carried headfirst as
prescribed by Army custom to a Humvee a
graves registration team took the body
for eventual burial in Arlington
National Cemetery I learned more about
sergeant Marshall in the coming weeks it
was fifty years old making him the
senior American soldier killed in the
war it served in the third Battalion of
the 15th Infantry Regiment a legendary
unit in the 3rd Infantry Division and he
died while firing a mark-19 automatic
grenade launcher at marauding Iraqi
paramilitaries the fatal RPG round had
blown him from his Humvee turret and in
the chaos of combat his corpse had been
left behind
born in Los Angeles Marshall had joined
the army at 18 his father Joseph was an
army quartermaster during World War two
his mother
I have been a medical technician in the
Women's Auxiliary Army auxilary Corps an
unusual distinction for a black woman in
those days
Odessa Marshall would wear her uniform
to her son's funeral
sergeant Marshall had left the Army for
four years in the 1980s in a successful
fight against Hodgkin's lymphoma with
the cancer in remission he rejoined the
service the war in Iraq was his first
combat tour and he was nearing
retirement his survivors included a
widow Denise and six children ages 9 to
17 they collected his posthumous Bronze
Star and his Purple Heart in a political
democracy every soldier's death is a
public event every soldier's death ought
to provoke the hard question why did he
die even without having met sergeant
Marshall I could surmise that he had his
own answers his rank indicated enough
time and service to have sorted out such
existential issues later I would learn
that in his last dispatch home he saw a
little merit and debating the mission in
Iraq it's really not an issue with me he
wrote I'm not a politician or a
policymaker
just an old soldier any doubts on my
part could get someone killed but
private rationales
however valid and honorable rarely
satisfied public inquiries why did
sergeant Marshall die if you find
yourself ruminating on that question as
I hope you do and I think we must then
you too are in the company of soldiers
thank you very much I look forward to
your questions
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
harren raise your hand to raise your
hand again here there we go
I'd like to ask you about the embedding
of journalists with combat units do you
think that it was because of the
undeniable compelling nature of the
stories of the boots on the ground that
it obscured the larger picture of what
was going on and if so do you think that
was by intent well it's a good question
and it's an issue that is debated in
journalistic circles intently a year
later and it's debated in the military -
there were 777 embedded journalists 20%
of them incidentally were not American
citizens about 500 and some of us
crossed into Iraq the stated intent from
the Pentagon was to allow reporters to
have an inside view of what units were
doing in a way that had not been done
particularly during the Persian Gulf War
of 1991 when I think almost no one was
satisfied with coverage my personal
feeling and embedding was not a new
concept the third time I went to Somalia
I was embedded with the Marines had been
embedded with the 1st Armored Division
in Bosnia but my own personal feeling
was that if someone who's been around
the army all my life my father was an
infantry officer I've reported on the
army and the other services
professionally for many years this was
an a uniquely intimate view I've never
seen the inside of the army the way I
saw it this time there are hazards to
embedding there's no doubt about it one
of the hazards is the danger of being
co-opted it's something that reporters
need to watch out for at something that
is not unique to covering the hundred
and first Airborne Division you can be
co-opted if you are in the company of
people you admire and people with whom
you share a hardship people in this case
and musi died I think it's possible
possible to be co-opted if in fact
you're covering the Tennessee Titans or
you're covering the Louisville City
Council
it's one of the things that
distinguishes good reporters from less
good reporters it's the capacity to
maintain some distance and the requisite
objectivity to write about it warts and
all even when it hurts as for not seeing
the larger strategic issues I was
looking at the world through a soda
straw and I had no illusions that I was
seeing anything other than what I could
see essentially through general
Petraeus's eyes and the eyes of his
subordinate commanders and his soldiers
I think that if there were deficiencies
and covering the larger strategic issues
and I'll stipulate that there were there
always are in part it's because when
you've got 777 reporters out there they
tend to slice and dice the world into
very narrow strips and it's difficult to
put it together into a large panorama
was it intentional by the Pentagon I
don't think it was to be honest with you
I think what the Pentagon was trying to
do I know what the Pentagon was trying
to do in part was to have what they
thought were honest witnesses out there
to bear witness in case the Iraqis
claimed that there were atrocities by
the invading army as well as to provide
a conduit back home to the families
waiting and I know that that was quite
effective I think I heard a lot from the
families of the hundred and first that
they liked hearing about what their
soldiers were doing and in that case I
think it was successful mr. Atkinson
I've never served in the Army but I'm an
army daughter an army wife an army
sister and an army mother so I do
believe I have served
there's no pension is he no there isn't
my question to you is more of a
philosophical one the premise of the
professional soldier is to train for war
but if you say that war is indeed the
most corrosive thing to the human spirit
how do we reconcile this difference in
the fact that men and women choose a
career that is ultimately so corrosive
if they do have to act
in their capacity as a trained
professional well that's a good question
and how do you square that circle you
know first of all I think the profession
of arms is a noble calling and I think
it is a calling it's not for everyone as
someone once said it's like the church
it's not for everyone and so again I
stress that I do not suggest for a
moment that the sacrifice and the
demands on being a professional soldier
or even a soldier who serves one term
and goes on to college or whatever is in
any way diminished by this but I think
it's important to recognize that the
nature of war and I'm not just talking
about the war in Iraq in 2003 I lived in
World War two everyday I know I wrote a
check the other day and I dated it
January 10 1944 that's either a good
sign or a very bad sign
and the kind of corrosion that I'm
talking about this this this attack on
the spirit is something that is endemic
to all wars probably going back to the
Peloponnesian wars and before you
reconcile it I think by acknowledging
the need for an army and I'm talking
about all the services here of course
the fact that they protect us the fact
that they provide the bulwark against
assaults on our freedom the fact that
they allow us to enjoy the quality of
life that we've got and at the same time
when they go off to war first of all you
have a responsibility I think to make
sure that it's the right war and that
the sacrifices both the physical
sacrifices and the spiritual sacrifices
are in fact commensurate with the gains
I don't think you can do more than that
as a people it's part of the body
politic it's it's part of how we operate
as a people and have for 230 years or so
so you know I don't have a magic
rhetorical bullet to make make it go
away I'm just telling you it's there and
it's something we should be aware of
thanks for the good question mr.
Atkinson at the beginning you asked how
many people had served in the armed
services I would like for you to ask the
question now as to how many people here
have someone presently serving in their
family and their services and then
comment on those numbers as compared to
the prior numbers okay if you heard a
question how many of you have family
members serving in the military now
would you raise your hands well it's a
whole lot it's a little hard to see up
here in the lights I can't tell whether
the first raising of hands was larger
than the second you know the point of
fact is that we are in amazingly
considering that we do not have a dry
armie we do not have sons and daughters
as two generations ago who were in
certain jeopardy of being drafted into
the army where they wanted to go or not
but yet we're invested as a people the
hundreds of folks in this room either
have direct experience have served
directly or you've got loved ones who
are serving and you know the burden and
the sacrifice that I'm talking about I
don't know how to comment more than that
other than to say that every time I talk
to people all around the country and
particularly when I talk to young people
on college campuses and so on where
they're generally not thinking about
going into the army of the Navy of the
Air Force and the Marines I try to
remind them that there are people just
like you just like you I have a 20 year
old son and an 18 year old daughter and
they aren't going in the military and I
preach to them there are lots of people
just like you who are making tremendous
sacrifices on your behalf don't forget
it
that's all you can ask mr. Atkins from
the last time you were here you
commented on how the Army in World War
two was equipped and I was wondering
what your view was of our army in Iraq
and it's equipment the army in general
in Iraq in 2003 and today in 2004 is
immensely superior to the army that went
into North Africa say on November 8 1942
its superior in its training its
superior in its education level its
superior in its preparations across the
board and it is way superior in terms of
equipment it is like an army from a
different planet today compared to that
army in 1942 there are lot of things
that are familiar to a soldier from 1942
if you were looking at an infantryman
today for example he would recognize the
infantry waddle he'd recognized the
concerns of an infantryman he would not
recognize
to a large extent the the equipment that
he's got and there were things that in
this recent war were not even available
in the Persian Gulf War in 1991 I'll
give you one example and it was a
remarkable thing to watch the military
developed something called blue force
tracker and blue force tracker is a
system that allows you to put small
electronic devices that emit a signal
and you can put them on tanks you can
put them on Humvees you can put them on
armored personnel carriers you can put
them on helicopters and they transmit a
signal to a satellite and it is back to
a receiver which can display all these
blue icons of where these individual
vehicles are on a screen so the general
Patraeus sitting in his Tactical
Operations Center could see on this
screen where such-and-such a platoon was
where such-and-such a company or
battalion was it provides astonishing
situational awareness to use the
military term it's one of the reasons
why there wasn't more fratricide in this
conflict and it's one of many
developments from the kind of rucksacks
the soldiers carry right up to the kind
of munitions and that the predominance
of precision munitions today even
compared to twelve years ago in the
Persian Gulf War so I think we're
treating them pretty well in terms of
the equipment that you got soldiers tend
soldiers that I talked to and was with
tended to be quite happy with the kit as
the British call it you may address this
in the book I don't know but in the
papers following it reaching Baghdad and
so forth the general Wallace the corps
commander whom he spoke of was quoted as
having said something to the effect and
I guess the the post back there there
that they didn't prepare us for this or
I don't know the exact words but having
been close to the command there and him
I suppose I wondered what whether there
was reaction to that by the yeah I know
exactly what he said sir because he said
it to me and we weren't in Baghdad yet
it was still fairly early in the war it
was roughly March 28th and it was during
the terrible sandstorm the three-day
sandstorm that you'll recall when the
army and its drive toward Baghdad had
essentially stalled as a consequence of
the conditions and the conditions
included marauding attacks by Iraqis on
the supply lines that had not been
anticipated there was a belief that when
the Army and the Marines blew into Iraq
that the Shiite majority in the southern
part of Iraq would welcome them as
liberators expect parades was the phrase
that came from Washington and in fact
that didn't happen initially they were
greeted with gunfire and there was a
change of plan no plan survives contact
with the enemy proverbially and they had
to subdue these cities general Wallace
showed up at at Forward Operating Base
shell to see General Petraeus and I
asked general Wallace after he had
conferred with Petraeus how he felt
things were going basically and he said
the enemy were fighting is is different
from the enemy we war gamed against and
he elaborated on that a bit and what he
meant was we didn't anticipate these
suicidal attacks from the Fed again the
Iraqi diehards the bath party members
attacking out of cities and using the
cities of sanctuary threatening this
very thin thread of a supply line that
stretched all the way back to Kuwait how
was it received it was received very
poorly frankly
by the White House in particular general
Wallace whom I adore is a very competent
combat commander and a real straight
talker and you ask him a question and he
will give you a straight answer and this
caused all kinds of heartburn in
Washington where they were running
around with their hair on fire
mainly because it was at odds with the
assertions out of the Pentagon in
particular and out of the White House to
some extent that everything was going
swimmingly and that in fact we were we
were virtually in Baghdad and the war
was going to be over soon and it from
the field it just didn't look that way
Wallace essentially was it was suggested
to him that he hold his tongue he did he
rejiggered his plan and I think
ultimately felt that what he had said
was a bit of a tempest in a teapot I saw
him in August and we both agreed that we
were puzzled by the storm that this
kicked up he's currently the commander
at Fort Leavenworth and he remains a
great soldier
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Rick Atkins in his author of an army at
dawn crusade and the long gray line his
latest in the company of soldiers is
number eight on this week's New York
Times nonfiction bestsellers list it's
published by Henry Holt on the web at
Henry Holt com
[Music]